[Music]
uh we'll just start out with this basic
thing
where i can use file inputs
to upload
anything
that i'd like
which is cool
but this
pull request was asking if we could add
a capture attribute to file input
to enable what was it again vera to
basically enable the front facing camera
yeah to enable the camera uh input
um there was already an accepts argument
to
file input there was not the capture
attribute
right
right so file input
has a handful of arguments and except
allows us to upload various different
types of files is that
so we can say accept is image slash star
so that you can only upload images you
wouldn't be able to upload a csv or
something like that i see
i say accept
video slash star
image
slash star
now if i run this again
you can do your
uh i can upload my pngs but i can't
upload
targets
anything else yeah like pdfs
oh
okay right
so and if we actually look at the return
value
of file input
it's a pretty big complicated html tag
that's being returned
so there's like an outer
div
uh
which is the actual shiny input
container that you'll see around a lot
of shiny input functions
and that's just kind of a class to let
the shiny javascript know like hey this
is an input container that has input
value
that we should send back to the server
that that
you could access in the server code
um
but you know there's all this sort of
complicated markup and then finally
at the end of the day
there's an input tag
that is the actual
html element that enables the file
uploading
so essentially
we have this accept argument on file
input that gets routed to this accept
attribute on the input tag
so
we have this kind of general problem
with a lot of like shiny input functions
where
we're basically wrapping html tags and
in some cases you know you might want to
customize certain attributes on
particular tags um on this return value
and
we might not
sort of out of the box provide you the
tools to
be able to customize like a very
particular attribute on a very
particular tag in this return value
so
this person was kind of requesting like
hey
there's this capture attribute on
um
an html input tag
that allows you to
enable
the front-facing camera on a mobile
phone so this would allow him to kind of
do like a facial recognition thing
uh or allow somebody to like
capture a video of themselves and then
upload it to a shiny app
and
we've been working hard on tools to
basically allow you to more generally
take the return value of something like
file input and target a very particular
say html elements like the input
element
within this return structure
and do something like append an
attribute which is effectively what this
user is asking for
is
hey could you add an argument to file
input to
basically customize the capture
attribute on this input tag
so
you know
we're trying to avoid going down this
sort of rabbit hole of trying to cover
every html attribute on every sort of
shiny ui function you could imagine
and providing better tools for doing
this sort of thing where
this user could
instead of just having the file input
here
basically
do something like this
where
instead of having this is the return
value where i have this input where it's
of type text
class form control placeholder
read only and the input above it as well
yes this is the actual input that's
relevant
good
good
pointing that out
we can use this tag append attributes
which
uh effectively
um does some css selector magic to say
within this html structure that's being
returned by this first argument here
find the first input tag so it'll go in
and find this input tag here
and append an attribute of capture user
so that's adding this part here
we could even do
because it selected actually both input
tags because there's no distinguishing
marker
we could do a id foo
on the css right right right
so
um
the css selector
uh this when i just type out input it's
basically going to look for a tag name
of input
that's just kind of how css selectors
work
but there's some special characters that
you can add to css selectors
where i could tack on a
hashtag or pound sign
and then
an id name
so as barrett pointed out i could do
pound sign who
and that would make sure that instead of
the selector matching both input tags
notice how the capture user is only
being added to this input with an id of
food instead of this one as well so
yeah with tag append attributes this is
this is actually a fairly recent feature
that we've added to tag append
attributes
in
the past you've had to kind of
maybe some of you have already done
something like this where
if you actually look at the structure
like the r representation of this html
it's a big
mess of complicated list structures that
you get back
and there's a very good reason why we do
this it's you know
by having like an actual formal
structure to these html tags it allows
us to compose them
in interesting ways and do sort of
magical things like this tag append
attributes but this is not something you
want to work directly with
so like way early on in html tools you
might have you know had to do something
like
x dollar let me reach into the children
of this top level div tag
and then look at what's in there
um
it's a list of three
where the first list is a label the
second list is a div that holds the
input tag
so let me actually reach into the second
childs and i actually want to get into
the children of this div so now i'd have
to do this
and now i'm getting closer to getting to
this actual input that i want
but
now i need to reach into this first item
get into the children so as you can see
here this is not something you want to
actually
we've
part of what inspired some of this work
is we've seen a lot of code out
in the ecosystem doing this kind of
stuff to do custom ui work
and we wanted to make it a lot
less
confusing how to do something like this
and
also make your code a lot
less brittle to breaking changes that we
make to kind of the html that we're
returning in these functions so i've had
to go out and actually you know fix
cases like this because we wanted to
slightly tweak the actual html that
we're returning
where this is like making very strong
assumptions about the relative ordering
of these tags
um
and
you know working with an api that's like
not super public and something we don't
really want to encourage you to actually
be doing
so it's a lot better to like actually
reach in and get
that subset of html that you're looking
for and modify it using something like
this
yeah
like placing a needle within the
haystack in a very specific location
versus rummaging through and going
i hope and then leaving it
and so actually what powers this css
selector argument and
the ability to kind of like subset down
find a particular subset of this html
and then modify it
is
powered underneath the hood by sort of a
lower level tool that you can if you're
kind of a power user and need to do
something a little bit more
sophisticated than
something like tag append attributes
would provide
we
also
have
this api
called tag query
and if you've ever used
jquery in javascript this api will look
very similar to what you already do with
jquery
so we're not really inventing
a new wheel here we're just kind of
borrowing some of the best ideas of what
makes jquery
or what made jquery such a great project
and you can find this article here at
rstudio.github.io
html tools
this is a fairly new website we only
have one article as of now that gets
into
tag query but hopefully
we'll get some more documentation
surrounding html tools
and if if you're kind of confused like
if you haven't really heard of html
tools before
html tools
provides kind of the html foundation for
shiny
so when something like file input
returns all of this html structuring all
of that
all of those data structures and that
writing of html logic is all done by
each
this sort of lower level html tools
package
and you might have never had to do
something like library html tools before
even if you've written custom html
because shiny re-exports functions from
this package
so you might might have written like
library shiny and then like
create a custom html div or something
like that
because you get those functions when you
load shiny but
if you load html tools you'll get some
other functions like
tag query um tag append attributes some
other functions for doing like lower
level html tool thing or html things
that
you know not a whole lot of shiny apps
will be doing
so
with tag query um
the main idea is that you can pass it
either a tag object like a div
or
you know equivalently something like the
return value of file input
i could pass directly into tag query
and
there's kind of two main components to
this return structure
one is this
it's actually a class with methods
so this is showing you if i called the
alt tags class
i basically get the return value that i
that i fed into this tag query
um so it might not be clear why why it's
set up this way right now but eventually
we're going to like
modify the input value essentially in
this tag query
object
and then the other method is this
selected tags um method which will will
allow me to do something like if i want
to find
all the input tags essentially what we
had before with css selector equal to
input
the equivalent way of doing this with
tag query is to say dollar find input
and that is going it's not going to
update the alt tags output of this
tegury object
but it will essentially
subset down the selection from being you
know by default
the input that i gave it
it will update the selected tags to both
of the input tags
so
now i could do something like
chain a call to selected tags and now i
have a list of length two containing
both of the
input tags that i might want to do
something with and i don't think i can
just kind of on a whim
explain
better what take query actually
provides than sort of this vignette so i
do recommend
reading through this
but kind of the first portion of this is
all about this
like find method and similar methods
like children
where find will find it'll traverse
essentially all of the descendants of
the top level tag
and find all occurrences of
html tags that match
the css selector that you've given it
so that's why
i was able to use fine here and it
traverses everything and it reaches in
to like several
descendants down into this input
tag here
but
if you wanted to do something like
for some reason
only consider the direct children which
would be this label
div and this other div
if i search for children
there's going to be no selection
associated with that
that matches the input right
but if i wanted to like find
a label tag there is a direct
child's
label tag here
so that will match on this
label
so in the case of an action button like
it's a simple like one
single button tag
which
allows us to kind of design this
function interface as routing all
additional arguments that you might want
to provide
to this button tag so that allows you to
do things like
my action button with an id of foo
a label here
and that creates this button html with
an id a type
and some default classes to give its
like default bootstrap styling
but say i want to add like a custom
inline style of like i want to increase
the font size to
basically two units of line height
you can do something like that with
action button
because it
basically is like
doing the lower level tags dollar button
and providing a style to that directly
since we sort of take the dot dot dot
and route it directly to the tags button
it's essentially the same
interface
so in the case of action button it's a
very thin wrapper where you don't really
need
um this sort of ability to
you know take the return value and then
modify attributes you can just do that
in one shot directly
when calling action button
um and you can you know since these
uh
again is just kind of taking any sort of
input value and feeding it in the button
if i wanted to i could
pass another tag
object into that and like i don't know
create
just an empty div
oh actually that's
for icon
i think i'd have to explicitly
say icon is not what is now
yeah so that is kind of an unfortunate
thing about
the way this is set up um
is you would have to make sure like what
was happening here is this tags dollar
div
instead of going into the dot dot dot
here since i hadn't specified an icon it
was treating it like the third argument
here
um but if i wanted to like
take a tag object and have it run
through this dot dot dot
i could you know fully specify those and
make sure that it's going to the dot dot
dot there and then
shows up in my html again like the tag
query append attributes css selector
stuff isn't super useful for this
but it's more useful in a case where you
have like a lot of
like a big complicated html tag
structure and you need to get at a
particular subset of that we did
basically just cover
you know with the tag and tag append
attributes you have the ability to find
subsets with this css selector
and then ability to append attributes
but there's more that you can do
than just appending attributes
you can also do things like append
children
so and you'll notice
these other
this other append
function
also has a css selector argument
so you could do a similar thing where
you know
again here's my file input if i wanted
to
say insert
another div within this input group
i could search for
a class of input group
and append
a child tag of just a div
and i'll just give it a class of my
custom class
and i should load
html together
oh
thank you
and now i actually get
this div of class my custom class
inserted by default i guess
in
as like the last child
within this input group
tag so kind of like there's basically
two main ways you might want to modify
the html either like mess with the
attributes
on the tag or add or remove
tags
so
if it's as simple as wanting to
like
add an attribute or modify an attribute
or
append
a single child like this
you can use these sort of higher level
tag append child or append attributes
um but
as some of these examples get into you
can use this tag query to do
more sophisticated stuff um
and let me try to find
an example of
i could do like remove class ad class
with like button success instead of
button default
right
um yeah so
let's try out tag query with this action
button
so by default this button tag is going
to be selected and as barrett was saying
um
let me actually save this
as
an object called btn
then when i type dollar i'll see all of
the available methods on this tag query
class
so we've already seen
stuff like find and children
um there's also siblings parents and
parents and this kind of helps you
traverse
that tree where say you like went to a
particular subset but then you actually
want to go back to a parent
or find a sibling
tag
you can use use those methods
but he was mentioning
maybe i want to
[Music]
for some reason take off this btn
defaults class
i could do something like remove
this btn
default class
and this will actually modify
um the btn
object and we do that for performance
reasons that's that's why this is kind
of like even like a lower level
developer kind of more developer facing
tool than this api
um where it's not
modifying the input
object here
it's giving you basically a copy of that
input value
as its return value
whereas using take query more directly
like this actually will modify
the input tags that you give it
so
yeah so now i've removed btn defaults
and now i could
add a class of
say vtn
success
and now it's appended to the end here
and
maybe to make this
a little bit more motivating i'll just
show you what this something like this
would actually do
where that
is
interesting i thought by default
actually
it was going to come up as a blue
[Music]
color
but that is only going to come up as a
blue color if i add a class of btn
um primary
and that is a bootstrap specific thing
where again this is kind of like a hard
to discover sort of feature where
shiny
comes with
bootstrap
and bootstrap has these sort of semantic
css classes where
this btn and btn defaults like gives
that default sort of white
coloring with a border around it based
on bootstrap's defaults
but if you add an additional btn primary
class
that will give it this sort of blue
background
and border color
that makes it kind of pop out
so once you're kind of aware of those
kind of things and like more familiar
with how like bootstrap works or if
you're using some other
framework with shiny
um
knowing about these kind of tricks to
like add or remove classes from the
return value
will help you kind of
be able to leverage kind of the
scaffolding or the high level like
widgets that shiny provides to you but
also be able to do like some more custom
theming things with it
[Music]